I'm Mitch Danspey. I'm the Scoutmaster from Troop 404 in Norman Beach, Florida.
This edition of Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me,
And now it's the old Scoutmaster.
How many Scouts does it take to change a light bulb?
Well, just one, but it takes four days because Scouts do a good turn daily.
I hear the collective groan: Thank you,
Hey. this is podcast number 332..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast. This is Clark Green.
Hey, let's take a look at the mailbag.
Kevin Brew left a comment about podcast 329 and Kevin is in the United Kingdom
And he said: from a UK perspective, I've often said that badges should be a result of Scouts enjoying themselves,
whether camping, hiking, activities at weekly meetings and generally doing what Scouts do.
I see too many Scout leaders planning around the badges instead.
Yeah, that happens. I mean, you know we talk about horses and carts and things like that.
You know let's not get the cart before the horse. Have a lot of fun.
Do what Scouts do? The badges? they're there. They happen as a natural result.
Kevin Cookson is the Scoutmaster of Troop 8010 in Yuma, Arizona,
And he wrote in to say this: my Scouts have achieved a new level of understanding the patrol method-
Or maybe I'm the one who's finally figured something out.
I looked up an old blog post of yours dated September 26, 2012,- Troop leadership elections
And I went to our Tuesday night meeting and here's how it went.
The Scouts had known for months that elections were coming up.
I talked with my senior patrol leader about how he was going to run the elections,
explained what positions were elected, which were appointed, etc.
I told them they had 10 minutes and then I left the room.
That's simple. The new senior patrol leader came out, told me the results.
New patrols were formed and they had patrol leaders that even come up with new patrol names and yells.
I couldn't be more proud.
It's like you said: so much of the work of a Scoutmaster is really just getting out of the way.
With much gratitude for all you teach us Scouters.
Thanks so much, Kevin. I'm sure glad you let me know that.
Yeah, get out of the way.
You know Scouts understand how to make things happen.
They don't make things happen in the same way that adults do, but they get the job done
and then they gain experience, they learn, they build character.
What could be better?
Last week's podcast number 331 had these responses over on Facebook.
A lot of folks follow us on Facebook. by the way. I don't know if it's your thing,
but there's over 15,000 folks who look in on what's happening at ScoutmasterCGcom on Facebook,
So you might want to check that out.
James Montigny said: I love this advice in the way it's presented.
Thank you Well, thank you, James.
John McFadden said: spot on, as usual this week, and super relevant.
Thanks, John,
Glad we could be of assistance there.
And Brian Hildebrand left a big smiley face.
You got to love Facebook right.
Here's a big smiley face right back at you.
Every week I try to have a couple of live chat sessions.
It's been mostly once a week for the past several weeks,
But what you do is this here: mostly Tuesday mornings or Wednesday mornings.
If you keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed,
you'll see me announce that we're having a live chat session.
You come on over to scoutmasterCGcom, sign in, join in the chat, like Gary did this week,
who was on the chat for his first time.
Gary's a scoutmaster near Chicago.
Thanks for stopping in, Gary.
Lots of frequent flyers also stopped by
And we discuss things of great importance and zero importance,
But it's a way to a while away a little of your free time.
You have free time, don't you
Right?
Hey, I want to take a moment to thank all the folks
who are scoutmasterCGcom backers.
Thank you so much.
We keep things moving and joining. the many people who help support the podcast
financially this week are Jill Blantz, Victor Malhar and Tonya Cornelius.
They've added their names to the list of scoutmasterCGcom backers
since our last podcast.
Thanks to to all of you who've added your support, to the many folks
who help us make the blog and podcast possible through Patreon.
Patreon's kind of like a monthly subscription. becoming a backer.
It's like a one-time thing,
But if you'd like to become a backer or join our Patreon subscribers,
visit scoutmasterCGcom.
You'll find links to follow at the top right of any page
and links in this episode's podcast notes.
Well, in the remainder of this week's podcast,
I've got some email questions to answer,
So let's get started, shall we?
Across the nation, communities and the parents of Boy Scouts
are observing Boy Scout Week,
Agreeing with the boys themselves that adventure, that scouting.
Write me a letter, send it by name.
Email, that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
This first email question comes from Jeff and he says:
as a scout master, I continually have this issue.
Our Scouts move through the ranks and that position of responsibility
is needed, typically a four or six month term.
Our leadership term runs October through March and April through September
After the senior patrol leader election.
I encourage the Scouts to write up a brief paragraph
of the leadership role they're interested in
and why the senior patrol leaders should appoint them.
I will sit down with the senior patrol leader
and review the submissions and any leadership positions available.
If a scout has not spoken to the senior patrol leader
or submitted a leadership request,
they are usually not chosen for a leadership position.
Some Scouts have even indicated that they do not want
a leadership role due to sports conflicts
or if they want to take a break from being a leader.
Now my issue is the performance of the youth leaders.
Several youth leaders don't attend patrol leaders council,
don't go on camp outs,
attend less than half of the troop meetings
or do nothing in their leadership role.
Now I speak with them and remind them of their responsibilities
as the leadership term progresses.
Later I will get a request for a scout master's conference
and I will ask them:
well, what have you done with your leadership role?
They usually will respond with nothing,
so I will not sign off and recommend them for a border review?
I have one scout's been a historian for the past year.
During the last two years
he's been on zero camp outs,
attended 15% of troop meetings
and has not produced anything in the historian role.
Now this is typically a scrapbook with photos and writeups
of what's been happening during the year.
I've spoken with him multiple times,
gently reminding him of his role and responsibilities.
He said that he'll do better
than he's absent for the next four to six weeks.
He's now asking for a scout master conference for life rank
and I've asked him to show me the efforts of his role
as a historian before I recommend him for a border review.
So this brings me to my two questions:
Am I being out of line for refusing to sign for a scout
who has not done anything in a leadership role,
and how do you encourage scouts to fulfill a leadership role?
Well, Jeff, let's start with the second question first.
I think the answer to the question-
how do you encourage scouts to fulfill leadership role-
is more about the perspective that you have
on the way these positions work.
When there's things to do
that are vital, practical and engaging,
you know scouts will roll up their sleeves
and get things moving.
If the role that they're in isn't vital
or practical or engaging,
they don't pay too much attention to those roles,
And you know who would.
If it's not going to be something that is valuable
to me as a scout or to making things happen,
why am I going to be bothered with it?
That's just the way. I think at least
Most of us find dealing with the issues
that you've outlined challenging,
So let's see if we can unwind some of this.
The first challenge is to understand.
there are no leadership positions mentioned
in any of the rank requirements,
Only positions of responsibility,
And that's an important distinction,
because not every one of the positions
of responsibility necessarily require
what we would normally identify as leadership skills.
The ones that do, it's pretty obvious
because they have the word leader in them,
like patrol leader, senior patrol leader,
assistant senior patrol leader.
That's not to say that guys occupying other roles
won't have leadership qualities and exercise them,
But I think it's an important distinction.
So let's talk about roles of responsibility
And when we talk about these,
the first question ought to be what needs to be done,
not who needs to fulfill a rank requirement
or who submitted a leadership request,
And we addressed this a couple of podcasts back.
You know, youth leaders aren't employees of the troop,
They're active players in a game.
I get the idea of submitting a leadership request
on a piece of paper, but really
to me it invites all kinds of associations
with business and industry and employees.
I would stay as far away from that as possible.
Now, if you remember you go back a couple of podcasts.
We talked about this responsibility as the horse.
The program is the cart
And advancement is the track. the cart leaves behind.
A horse without a cart or a cart without a horse
is not going to leave the right kind of tracks right.
So we need the combination,
We need them all put into perspective,
We need them hooked up the right way.
But there has to be something to do.
There has to be a program to do it for
And then you get the results that you're looking for.
The program's there,
It's ready to go, but it can't go on its own.
It's all words and books and words on pieces of paper.
It doesn't have muscles or lungs or a heart.
The program is just sitting there.
Responsibility is where all the heart and muscle is.
That's the way things happen.
Advancement can't go on its own.
It's the result of action,
It's not the actions themselves.
The positions of responsibility are there to make things go,
Not to parse out advancement opportunities.
So encouraging scouts to do something about their position of responsibility
has to do with the nature of the position itself and your perspective.
It can't just be why don't you do your job,
You know. it can't just be that.
It has to be something that a scout sees as being vital and engaging
and important to the life of his patrol and his troop.
The first question you asked- which I am answering second
is everybody keeping notes- was:
am I being out of line for refusing to sign for a scout
who's not done anything in a leadership role?
When a scout hasn't achieved our expectations,
we have to first ask if those expectations were actively shared
or just kind of passively implied.
I mean, you can't hand a scout a sheet of paper with expectations.
That never works.
You have to actively discuss those expectations
and then get them to develop a set of shared expectations.
You have to collaborate on this.
It's our responsibility to assure that from the get-go
there's a shared expectation that the scouts understood them
and then, to you know, monitor their progress
in achieving those expectations.
So in the particular instance that you talk about, Jeff.
you've got a scout who has gone for a year without doing anything
and I've got to say that's actually more our fault as scouters
than anything else.
Allowing a scout to remain in the position for a year
without requiring any results is a very clear message to him.
There's no problem with the way you're doing this.
I guarantee that is what this scout thinks,
because he's asking you for a scout master's conference
for life rank.
So he's pretty sure there's no problem.
Now you say that you gave him some reminders
and you discussed with him,
You encouraged him and everything, and that's great.
But scout age boys are not susceptible to gentle reminders
for the most part.
Most of the time they have to have things very clearly
spelled out.
They are literalists,
They do not take hints.
There has to be a continual engagement and evaluation,
because scouts do not have a good handle on their schedules.
Their level of excitement about responsibilities
is highly variable and you can be very direct about this
without being unpleasant.
One of my stock questions is when I'm concerned
that a position of responsibility is not really
being actively taken on is to say, hey, what have you done
towards fulfilling your responsibilities this past week?
A lot of times the answer is: well, I've been really busy,
I've got a lot of homework,
I'm playing football, whatever,
And I just haven't had time to do anything.
And you know what?
That's fine.
And I say that. I say, look, we all have weeks like that.
Let's look at next week.
What specifically will you be doing this week
And when will you do it?
What will I be able to ask you the next time we get together-
And in the instance that you shared, Jeff, you're talking
about a historian who's supposed to be making a scrapbook.
Maybe he tells you: you know what?
I'm going to get a scrapbook on Wednesday and get started.
That's great.
Bring the scrapbook with you next week.
Show me how much progress you've made
Now. if he hasn't made any progress by the next week-
and this is probably exactly what will happen-
If he's not interested or engaged in the whole thing
next week, he'll show up.
You'll say: did you bring the scrapbook?
No, didn't have time to get it.
Then I would tell him this:
Look, if you don't have the time to do this right now
or you're not really interested in doing this, I understand.
There's no problem. no harm, no foul.
Would you like to pass this on to someone else,
Or do you think you really want us to be able to continue?
If the answer to that question is the affirmative yes,
I really want to continue in this-
Then the deal is: something must happen by next week.
That's a non-negotiable term.
Something must happen.
You need to show me what's happened next week.
If the answer is no, then that's fine.
Tell them you'll work with the senior patrol leader
past the responsibility onto somebody else
and when this guy is ready,
when he has the time and the interest,
we'll get them a responsibility.
Now, if week three rolls around
and there's no progress,
I'm going to say that we've discussed how important this is
for you to make some progress on getting this done.
If you can't honestly do it, I understand
and apparently that's the way that it is,
But there is no way we go on past next week.
Specifically, what can I expect?
When will we talk next week
And then get an answer,
have a shared expectation about what's going to happen
and say, look, that's great.
I want to make sure you understand something:
If we get to next week with zero progress,
then I'm going to tell the senior patrol leader
to pass this responsibility onto someone else.
Have you heard and understand exactly
what our agreement is here.
So let me go back, because this is kind of a step one,
two, three, four thing,
which I'm not normally very fond of.
but listen to the spirit behind the thing.
The first time out is to say:
so, what have you done?
If the answer is I haven't done anything,
then you say: okay,
so what's your plan for next week
and what will you have done?
And you have a collaboration,
you create a shared expectation.
The next week rolls around,
likely, it's not, nothing's happened.
You say, okay, yeah, I know
We all have weeks like this.
Let's get back up and running next week.
Definitely this is going to happen.
Then we get to that next week,
nothing's happened. again.
And then you say, okay,
look, this is what must happen by next week.
If it doesn't happen,
I'm instructing the senior patrol leader
to pass the responsibility on to someone else,
because you're either not interested
or you don't have the time, and that's fine,
And there'll be a position of responsibility
for you when you do have the time,
and one that you're interested in.
If you don't have any results for me next week,
that's what's going to happen
Now. do you understand that?
Do we have a shared expectation.
Now, if that scout never shows up,
I've got to pick up the phone
and have that conversation right.
But there has to be a point of action
or a point of moving on
And, Jeff, I would suggest consider shortening the time
that scouts spend in particular positions
of responsibility.
Six months or a year is really an eternity
for a scout-age boy,
And even most adults that I know now
would find making an absolute commitment
for the next year or the next six months
to be very challenging,
if not impossible,
because there's a number of commitments
a scout or an adult has to balance
in taking on any kind of responsibility
and making a commitment towards it.
You can think that that's a horrible character flaw.
The way that our lives are ordered
in this day and age is very complex.
The way a family's life works is very complex.
The way a young person's life works is very complex,
And if you want to fight with that complexity,
go ahead.
I don't want to fight with it.
I want to make scouting work
for every single young person
that I can make it work for,
And I can do that
without diminishing expectations or standards.
It's not that difficult to do.
I'll tell you what we've been doing
and experimenting with.
We fill positions of responsibility
every three months
And we do that
based on the commitments
for going camping
for the next three months
And that way
there's no question
as to whether or not key youth leaders
will be on camping trips
or at meetings,
because they can't accept
a position of responsibility
unless they're committed to being on all
the camping trips
and at all the meetings,
or at least you know
the majority of the meetings.
And that's for a three month period of time
And it roughly corresponds
to the quarters at school,
So that school activities,
extracurricular activities at school,
kind of mesh with that.
So you know
if you're going to be in the marching band,
you're going to play football,
you're going to be a wrestler,
you're going to be a basketball player
and that's going to consume all of your free time
outside of school
for the next three months,
which is usually what the season is.
No harm, no foul.
We expect that.
But you know,
to make things work smoothly
for the patrols
and for the troop,
we're asking for a commitment upfront.
Tell us what you're doing
for the next three months
and then we'll make some decisions
about who it would be appropriate
to offer positions of responsibility.
I mean when we work with scouts,
we have to accept the idea
that they likely have
no earthly idea
of the things that we take for granted.
A few scouts are really capable and responsible,
but most need a lot of experience
before they truly understand
the dynamics of all this.
because we are familiar with business practices,
We tend to use them
when dealing with scouts
and positions of responsibility,
but I'm going to say it again
and I'll keep saying it,
and over and over:
They are not our employees.
Scouts is not a business.
You are not the boss.
Positions of responsibility- and scouting,
to me at least,
is about working together
to get things done.
They're not about title
or privilege
or command structures.
It's all just this big grand game
that we get to be the coach
and the mentor.
We collaborate with scouts
to realize the wonderful opportunities
the scouting offers.
and this happens
one scout at a time,
one conversation at a time,
one week at a time,
and when we focus our efforts
on making scouts successful
in these positions of responsibility
rather than laying down a gauntlet
and challenging them
to be successful.
No, we focus on making them successful,
helping them out
as much as possible
and making our expectations realistic,
considering the complexity
of their lives
and their family's lives.
It's not an easy subject, is it?
It's not easy to do
and it shouldn't be easy to do.
It's one of the bigger challenges
of being a scouter.
The next question
comes from
Brian Frey,
who is the committee chair of crew 808
in Mililani, Hawaii,
and he says:
I'm working with some energetic youth
and dedicated scouts
to get a new venturing crew
established here in Hawaii
and I've accepted the position
of crew committee chair.
The crew president-
and if you're not familiar
with the way venture crews work, folks,
the crew president is a youth leader.
The crew president
would like to move away
from what our troop did,
which was to collect a permission slip
for each scouting event.
This proved to be time consuming
and kind of frustrating
for scouts and adult leaders
organizing the event.
The new procedure
would be to have the parent or guardian
sign one permission slip
for their youth annually.
This one time consent
would cover all the events
for the year.
I'm a little concerned
about this kind of approach.
I see the BSA
has an activity consent form
that looks like a per event form,
but it doesn't state that explicitly.
I'm curious to learn
if you've had any experience
with this type of thing
and, if so,
what is your approach?
Well, Brian,
I don't know
that there's any specific policy
that would prevent anyone
from doing an annual permission slip,
but I don't really think
it's very practical.
Anybody who's
listened to the podcast
or read the blog
knows I am a continual,
dedicated foe
of unnecessary paperwork-
and all paperwork in general,
by the way-
But I do understand
that some paperwork is important.
Permission slips indicate
to a third party
that a child is knowingly placed
in the care of an adult
other than a parent.
That's important.
They also share information
with families
about where to drop off
and pick up,
how to contact their child,
who's in charge
and what they will be doing
and where they will be.
So I think
all of that information
is important,
but it doesn't necessarily
only have to be shared
in a permission slip.
There's also the factor
of actually having
absolute solid plans
a year in advance.
I've never been able to achieve that
because we've always had to change something
and that may not be possible.
I know it would be for me
and probably would be for our troop,
What I mentioned in the previous answer-
the email- bears on this a little bit,
because what we started doing
is having a three month permission slip.
So we have
three months of activities
outlined on the permission slip
with all of the information
that I just mentioned:
the who, why, what, where and how.
It's a little bit lighter
lifting for families
and it's easier to administrate.
from our point of view,
Three months seems to be the limit
of a family's ability
to look forward and plan
and it's really challenging
for some families.
There's a lot of things
that recommend this idea
of looking three months ahead,
getting commitments three months ahead,
getting permission slips,
taking care of getting payments
three months ahead.
It cuts down on a lot
of fuss and bother
of doing it every single month.
It gives us
a very concrete idea
of what our participation will be
for a given activity
and, as I said in the answer
to the previous email,
helps us work with our scouts
to set up positions of responsibility
that are achievable
in a three month period.
and we are beginning
our second quarter of doing this.
the first quarter
it worked out pretty well.
The second quarter
took a little bit longer
to get off the ground with it
because we were also dealing
with rechartering
and other giant paperwork- snafus.
but give that some thought, Brian,
and see if that helps you
answer that particular question.
Hey, if you've got a question
for me and you'd like to get in touch,
it's very easy to do
and I'm going to tell you how
in just a moment.
Well, thanks so much for listening
to this 332nd edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
You'll find 1600 articles
and many, many additions
of the podcast at scoutmastercgcom.
While you're there,
you can subscribe
to receive updates,
but to the podcast by email.
You can also join us
in the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
There are around 1400 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook,
where you're much more
than just a face in the crowd.
We have, of course,
the tweeters on Twitter,
who type truly tremendous
and thoughtful tweets.
We pin Pultritude in his pictures
proffered publicly
with a parcel of prolific
pinners on Pinterest
and you can watch us
at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
but if you cannot face Facebook
and Twitter makes you better,
you no interest in Pinterest,
you don't put the you in YouTube.
That's all right. old timer,
Zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email.
You can get in touch with me,
Clark Green at Clark,
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
That's C-L-A-R-K-E
If all else fails,
find a bright red phone
with no dial.
It's an old-fashioned desk set.
It's usually sitting
on the commissioner's desk
under a glass dome.
Press the button on that phone,
I'll answer all,
and I'll be on the other end
to answer all your questions
By now. it should be abundantly clear
that the Scoutmaster blog
and Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of anyone other than myself.
I am not endorsed or sponsored
by any scouting organization,
or the Boy Scouts of America
for that matter.
No, it's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand
to scouters
and have a little bit of fun
along the way.
and speaking of fun,
that's right. folks,
here he is
our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.